hi i'm joe list mark normand here and
we're here at fordham university we're
going to take a spin around the museum
with our curator jennifer yeah she's
good
very lovely that's the kind of guy i got
a fist bump
so welcome to the fordham museum of
greek etruscan and roman art i trust
sure that's when you ride horses uh-huh
right
yes exactly is that what a trusting
means uh-huh wow
you know like a trust green mm-hmm
that's equestrian
ah don't question me all right why don't
we start
over in the corner here
[Music]
this is the harpo marks trophy yes i was
thinking susan boyle
yeah both work yeah maybe one one
the nose is bleeding yeah we got susan
boyle with a coke habit yeah
that's actually medusa she was
supposedly so ugly
that when men looked at her they turned
to stone oh well wouldn't that be a good
thing
yeah now what do they keep in these
usually
usually these are these were just
basically funerary so nothing was kept
in these
got it funerary yeah these went directly
to the tomb oh i remember my
grandfather's funerary we were all
drinking pretty heavily
are you irish i said yeah uh-huh okay
stereotype yeah
big one i turned to stone it's pretty
small these actually
maybe did contain something um grain of
some sort these were probably likely um
or at least
one of their potential uses were is
where's kitchen storage vessels
so what do we just hit us with the
number we came all this way 300 400
bucks so what you want to buy one of
these things
yeah i want to get this a swap meet i
got i got
i got one annie on me so look great in
our apartment yeah what do you guys
share an apartment yeah sometimes good
time share
what we have in this case are two
examples of ciner well
a scenery urn here and an ossuary ashes
bones oh wow conceptually really cool
isn't it
ashes and bones a great uh morning team
yeah
that's what i'm trying to do
crashes and bones
[Music]
what do you make of this little guy on
top in front of him what do you think
about that
what do you think oh i didn't see him
see oh look at that
yeah he looks like a pee-wee's playhouse
kid playhouse what about you what do you
think
is it a weather [ __ ] is this a
villanovan geometric
impasto circa 9th century by any chance
it is
that's extraordinary yeah i know quite a
bit it's extraordinary
he's either an ancestor figure which is
sort of like the guardian of the house
or he's an apotropaic figure do you know
what that means do you know what that
means you know what that means
not active do you know what it means
yeah yeah it's uh dominican
yeah i think it's acrobatic mm-hmm
all of these things you're all drawing
the right connection no it actually
means to ward off evil
[Music]
that's big right yes yeah the police are
applicated
yeah wow
you think this is beautiful i like it
and a detail
what do you think of that detail it's
nice it got some letters there maximus
shortest i think they could have better
details like a like a
flame shooting out the side like a
corvette yes
that kind of detail yeah yeah what goes
in here is this uh
from moving i'm still gonna decal
decal that's not a detail a decal decal
is where i get my drugs
you know decal on 38th sarcophagus
it means coughing so can i go to a
funeral and go hey a couple
it's a good-looking sarcastic good you
could do that sarcophagus actually means
flesh eating oh
i got a bunion here let's get that off
there we go
well i'm getting my pants off for this
one then yeah oh boy yeah i got some
bacteria
a whole mesopotamia this um
inscription thank you very much smart
having a hard time today you really are
by leaps and bounds well uh this
inscription tells us
that we hear that he was the father
who had the same name as the child
olivia's publius maximus
was member of the 12th urban cohort
which is essentially
a police precinct there's a black kid
one of the two
no he wasn't killed by the police oh he
said urban
right he was he was a member of the
police force ah
irish got it it's a good place to come
back do you call this an antique
that's older than an ant it takes like a
lamp this is a artifact this is an
antiquity
antiquity oh yeah yeah
okay antigua aruba
jamaica oh i wanna take it to bermuda
[Music]
bahamas
american pickers those guys over this
[ __ ] i
had to have it right what guy wouldn't
love this for his man cave
so those two are gay right totally a
couple of guys
antiques hey we drove here i didn't want
to say it
i do love antiques these look like
little marijuana pieces
like uh whistles duck calls they
are lamps oh okay i'm rubbing one of
those this looks like a uh
mouth harp oh it does i don't know you
know the ping
pong wing on my wall they're actually
called
boys i'll see you guys
next week thank god it's not saturday
the sabbath
i had to say it there yeah the old jews
even those guys are outraged they got
swords down here
swords how did i miss the swords
spearheads spear points
sword swans this
really isn't my material uh-huh so
i am just my best
wow these are great oh look at this tiny
little thing
i have heard that before this is pretty
great
telling me
[Music]
well i'm finished well comes back to
porn and gay for you guys doesn't it
well we love gay porn porn so we met
this this is what we're looking at now
uh yes it is
yeah this is excellent observation
we are looking at it you know where
we're looking i do
yeah what do you make of it always what
is it is this a votive head of a young
[Music]
god what man you say that it feels
motive
does it yeah yeah he votes that kid
a votive youth of a capitae velato which
is
the type of the type of um votive it is
it sounds like a starbucks beverage
a votive is something you offer in a
sanctuary
it's a religious practice got it you
offer something to the gods and
hopefully
you get something back mm-hmm a little
quid pro quo
so to speak oh like sounds of the limbs
like silence of the lamb
yes swept the oscars yes
picture director actor actress
screenplay the person who published
these in our catalog
suggested that perhaps they were part of
a a sarcophagus relief decoration until
it was on top of a sarcastic coffin
yes we don't know um
candy coffin i'm a coffin
turn your head in coffin yeah
i've heard of that uh-huh yeah check it
out
[Music]
this thing is really unbelievable here
this big giant
face oh it's a penis i think but
really i mean it kind of is but it's
anatomically
it looks like an arm yeah kind of that's
why
yeah it's a little uh fishy it might be
it's actually
he's got a little butt situation too oh
he's neat
sorry the molly kicked in
i can tell
that hurts so much oh
god uh yes ram-headed
drinking cup here i want you to put your
grill right up to there and then no his
face
yeah yeah that's the one and i want you
to see and
that now that's what you would see once
he had finished drinking his wine he
would turn into
a goat head oh
[Applause]
so even back then they had drinking
games oh i yeah uh-huh now was campus
rape a problem back then because it
seems to be
quite an epidemic right now i think it
was just rape no campus
yeah that they raped everywhere drinking
games are fun
i didn't know the romans invented that i
would say be more of a greek thing
oh fraternity right
yes oh my
hey they invented it well i've been joe
list
and i'm mark norm and we are a lot
smarter than we were at the beginning of
the day
you got that right i was a real idiot
sure were
i didn't want to tell you that one's
stung